resuelve el sistema de ecuaciones
lineales graficándolo las ecuaciones que
nos dan son 5 x 3 7 y 3 x 2 igual a 8
cuando no están pidiendo resolver el
sistema lo que nos están pidiendo en
realidad es encontrar la x ilife que
satisfacen ambas ecuaciones cuando nos
piden que sea graficando graficar esta
ecuación es dibujar los valores de xy
que satisface esta ecuación y graficar
esta otra ecuación es dibujar los
valores de xy ya que satisface esta otra
ecuación cuando nos piden entonces un
valor de xy ya que satisface a ambas
ecuaciones ese punto debe estar en ambas
ecuaciones o más bien debe estar en las
gráficas de ambas ecuaciones por lo cual
será la intersección de las gráficas
veamos si podemos hacer eso enfoquémonos
en esta primera ecuación
queremos graficar entonces 5x + 3 igual
a 7 y hay varias maneras de hacer esto
podemos poner la ecuación en la forma
pendiente ordenada o simplemente
podríamos dar valores en la tabla para
obtener los puntos de la recta hagamos
eso al final de cuentas solo
dos puntos para poder trazar la recta
obtengamos entonces los valores de xy
cuando x es igual a cero tenemos que 5
por 0 3 y es igual a 7 déjame hacerlo
por acá tenemos entonces que 5 por 0 + 3
porque es igual a 7 este término se va a
cero y aquí dividimos ambos lados entre
3 y que nos queda 3 entre 3 1 nos
quedaría igual a 7 tercios de igual a 7
tercios lo cual es igual a 2 enteros un
tercio si queremos escribirlo como
número mixto hagamos ahora que igual a 0
sigue es igual a 0 que tenemos por aquí
5 por x más 3 por 0 es igual a 7 este
término es igual a cero y nos queda 5x
igual a 7 dividiendo entre 5 ambos lados
obtenemos que x es igual a siete quintos
entonces cuando y es igual a cero x es
igual a siete quintos o un entero dos
quintos platicamos entonces
puntos para poder graficar esta línea o
una buena aproximación de esta línea
entonces cuando x es igual a 0 que es
igual a 2 enteros un tercio aquí lo
tenemos este es el punto 0,7 tercios
y cuando x es igual a 7 quintos
0 es decir cuando x es igual a 10 2
quintos es cerca de 1.5 aquí lo tenemos
igual a cero aquí tenemos los dos puntos
y vamos entonces a unirlos para obtener
la recta trazamos la recta siempre es un
poco difícil trazar una recta voy a
hacerla con una línea punteada se va a
ver algo así como esto usualmente cuando
te piden resolver un sistema de
ecuaciones por graficación obtienes
números enteros sin embargo vamos a
hacer lo mejor que podamos para ver
dónde se intersectan estas dos rectas
bien
entonces hagamos ahora la segunda recta
3 x 2 es igual a 8 voy a hacer lo mismo
tenemos que 3x menos 2 es igual a 8 y
voy a encontrar también la intersección
con el eje x y la intersección con el
eje y entonces cuando x es igual a 0 a
que es igual que vamos a hacerlo por acá
tres por cero menos dos porque es igual
a ocho este término es igual a cero
dividiendo entre menos dos ambos lados
obtenemos entonces que es igual a menos
cuatro entonces y es igual a menos
cuatro hemos encontrado entonces que la
intercepción con el eje y es en menos
cuatro y aquí tenemos el punto cero
menos cuatro hagamos ahora entonces de
igual a cero cuando llegue igual a cero
aquí lo vamos a sustituir y que tenemos
que tenemos que es 3x este término se
hace 0 3 x es igual a 8 dividiendo ambos
lados entre 3
resulta que x es igual a 8 tercios x es
igual 8 tercios vamos a graficar los 8
tercios es más o menos 2 entre los dos
tercios aquí está aproximadamente dos
enteros dos tercios así que este es el
punto ocho tercios coma cero déjame
entonces graficar la recta lo va a hacer
lo mejor posible voy a usar también una
línea punteada aquí estoy haciendo mi
mejor trabajo para hacer esta recta aquí
la tenemos y a simple vista si lo
calculamos a simple vista vemos que el
punto de intersección aquí cae en el
punto 2 menos 12 para la equis menos 1
para la y este es el punto aparentemente
es una solución con números enteros pero
es a simple vista tenemos que
verificarlo
esto es hecho a mano no es tan preciso
como debería ser entonces hay que
verificar si el punto 2 coma menos 1 que
obtuvimos aquí como punto de
intersección satisface estas dos
ecuación
si el valor de xy satisface a ambas
ecuaciones y por lo cual está en ambas
gráficas sustituyendo entonces dos menos
uno en esta primera ecuación que tenemos
cinco por dos más tres por menos uno
esto es igual a siete vamos a verificar
eso 5 por 2 es 10 3 por menos 1 es menos
3 y esto nos da igual a 7 hemos
verificado que este valor es
efectivamente 7 así que dos como menos
uno definitivamente está sobre esta
recta o satisface esa ecuación
verifiquemos ahora en la otra ecuación
aquí tenemos entonces que es 3 x 2 menos
dos por menos uno es esto igual a 8
veamos tres por dos es igual a seis
menos dos por menos uno esto es positivo
y es esto igual a 8 si efectivamente 6 +
2 es igual a 8 hemos obtenido entonces
que el punto 2 menos uno se encuentra en
ambas rectas
es decir satisface a ambas ecuaciones
y hemos podido resolver el sistema de
ecuaciones graficándolo